Dr peterson,
I'm considering going into the education
stream slash system.
Do you have any advice for me not to
become a mouthpiece for indoctrinating
young students?
Well,
one thing I would recommend is that you
don't write essays that you don't
believe in.
I think that's a sin.
I think it's a sin to use your words
falsely and the reason for that,
like there's a good series of social
psychology experiments that show,
like imagine that you bring someone into
a lab and you have them write an essay
about or fill out a questionnaire about
their political opinions.
You know,
so you get a baseline measure of their
political stance and then you asked them
to write a thousand words.
Maybe they identify as,
right,
wait,
and then you get them to write a
thousand word essay on why a particular
left wing position is true and then you
have them come back in two weeks and you
give them the same political belief
questionnaire.
They'll,
they'll have shifted quite radically
towards the left.
And the reason for that is that people
don't think through their positions in
great detail.
And so if you get them to think through
a contrary position in great detail.